it's been a couple of weeks but it is
time for hate reott mail what is hatred
mail here's a reminder if you're allowed
to shop for luxuries like food and
medicine then we should be allowed to
clap our hands together in a megachurch
patriot mail written by Patriots who
hate David Pakman because America and
because freedom this one is pretty
brutal this one's pretty brutal the
anti-semitism is back in full swing
take a look I'm more tired of this Jew
David Park man than I've ever been
why are Jews so opinionated one Jew two
opinions
two Jews for opinions for Jews eight
opinions exponential but this guy is a
denier of Christ so of goes with the
territory
a Jew from Argentina imagine that
trespasser on top of everything else I
admit though Hispanic Ashkenazi he's
damn handsome hate him though this
person seems strangely attracted to me
despite their anti-semitism that that's
kind of different I guess
the hate mail lately that I've been
getting it's a lot of masks and economy
stuff it's kind of conspiratorial it's
overwhelmingly you know I'm part of some
conspiracy to shut down the economy to
hurt Donald Trump coronavirus as a hoax
masks don't do anything or may actually
be killing people that's been a lot of
it and no good conspiracy theory in the
United States is missing anti-semitism
so a lot of it is tied into it's the
Jews who want people wearing masks or
it's the Jews who want to shut down the
economy or whatever it's very very vile
stuff but remember that you can fight
hate reott ism by using the coupon code
hey tree at 40 to get a 40% discount off
of the membership of your choice at join
pakman.com you save 40% with the coupon
code hey tree at 40 the hey tree it's
cry and independent media benefits that
spell
h80 our i/o t40